that's how I look at this question now
before I rub this off let me make a
couple of cautions this this was all
here thankfully for you to be honest is
not to be memorized not to be memorized
that's a good thing because you look at
that Nick Express to memorize that it's
not to you memorized number one because
it's awful but number two because you
have to show where it comes from okay
I'm only we only look at it in these
terms to show you that when you put
these together you do indeed get a
parabola that's the point that's all but
you can't use it okay and that's
actually a good thing for another reason
which is that usually you don't have it
in all of these really vague terms okay
usually you actually have numbers in
there as we do in this case which makes
it a lot easier to actually compute all
of these bits and pieces okay so let's
have a go at this part a okay now by the
way before I go on when you have a look
at the question just read some of the
questions with me right fine horizontal
range find greatest height show that the
balls nightmares above the road etc
right all of those questions that I just
read to you have nothing to do with time
right so even though here they're sort
of guiding you along and st. Jude's
equation apart music we depart those are
the kinds of signals to you to say
archaic this is going to be a superior
approach to this okay because I'm more
interested in x and y's it's only the
very end when you have a look at the
time of flight where you have to appeal
back to your time equations okay but for
the rest of them the equation apart is
michael elegant so first what we want to
do is get our displacement equation
support x and y so where i'm going to
begin is the described okay i'm going to
need to resolve the initial velocity and
then i can use those to evaluate on my
constants out okay so i think you've got
this 20 meters per second yeah the Alpha
they give you here is tan inverse of 4
on 3 10 inverse or four or three so the
ratio you've got here is for 23 for 23
okay except this side is not forwarding
this side is not 3 because it doesn't
fit Pythagoras does it for 3 is just the
ratio not the actual
it's so that preserve the ratio for 23
but to get the right hypotenuse so what
are these values going to be 12 and 16
right here's my x dot my initial x dot i
should say and here is my initial wider
okay great i'm going to use those in a
second let's begin horizontal
acceleration every projectile motion
question always 0 cool now I'm going to
do this in the short poem because I
think you've got the right working
Debbie you've got to do all the
constants and integrate and so on but
you're going to get to this you get a
constant and the cost that must be this
right you sub in the initial voices so
you get that ok integrate again to get
to displacement and because you're
starting at the origin the constant that
flies along here is zero problem ok now
you do with your vertical dimension ok
um there have been naughty and they
don't tell you what you should define
gravity to be but looking at the
question what they've assumed what they
want you to prove what can you assume
gravity to be negative 10 good because
you're gonna get that negative 5t
squared at the end ok so if i integrate
once ok that'll become negative terms
minus 10 T ok but then you sub in your
initial condition right so you get that
integrate one more time to get to your
vertical displacement and this will be
negative 5t squared plus 16 T you'll
have another constant here but I'm
starting at the origin so this constant
will be zero there go I mean you flip
them around that's it that's kind of why
I was surprised that it was taking so
long to get these good they don't take
long you always start from these to
every time every projectile motion
equations projectile motion question and
these will fall out ok now they didn't
tell you to do so but the point of this
is to say whoa okay if I put these
together well I get when I eliminate the
parameter ok so let's do it probably
easy stuff if i rearrange that make tea
the subject so you get this ok so when I
slide this into my Y equation here's
what I've got
um minus five there you go okay I could
tidied up a little bit but as it turns
out later there's not much point in
doing it because I'm going to be
multiplied through all this to get rid
of the awkward fractions and then solve
this thing okay so there you go there's
my equation apart once part being asking
for we want number one horizontal range
and number two greatest height okay so
horizontal range is how far am I going
to go over there right in X Y terms in
Cartesian terms that's just the root of
this equation that's not zero that's all
the root of this equation that's mod 0
okay so we can do that it's easy you can
say to find range or horizontal range
our system and this is actually the way
that I would set it out right try as
much as you can to avoid equations just
you know papi up in out of nowhere
without any explanation as to why okay
let y equal zero that's going to tell me
how far I go okay so there's my equation
okay what ought i to x to get rid of all
of these or full fractures probably
hundred forty-four I'm think I'd run for
you put that Gator don't get rid of this
guy it'll get rid of this guy and then
something that's that's okay right so
this will become minus 5x squared 16 x
12 12 x 144 and it's an extra forty
eight so I think it's some 192 okay
bigger so I want to solve this you can
clearly see you can clearly see that one
of the solutions x equals 0 naturally
but I want the other one don't I okay so
I'll just factor out let's see how
factor out an X which will give me this
182 minus 5x
so here are my two solutions okay what's
that 191 5 that's the better give it to
us today what is it decimal anyone
Twista 40 isn't it just a bit under 40
38.4 meters there you go there's the
horizontal range that are now the next
thing they want to us for his greatest
height greatest height now some of you
have gone to y dot equal 0 y dot equal 0
ok and then you've gone back to time you
can get the answer that way but the
point of doing this is that you don't
need to you don't need to you know that
the greatest height will line up exactly
halfway between where you start and
where you finish cuz it's a parabola it
has this axis of symmetry ok so all you
need to do is say there's no extra part
you just say when x is equal to and you
just have it you don't need to provide
any argument for that ok and you can sub
that into your equation apart right
there ok so you're going to get this ok
all you have to do is crunch the number
and I think we should get top on it so
you get tada see how simple that was
don't go back to time get a time value
then put that into why what a wasted
time ok just go straight there right